hey guys this is dennis the founder of
think here and i'm david griffin your
resident comic book and video game guru
and this is our breaking bad season five
uh preview for the second half this last
eight episodes ever right of breaking
bad it's very sad so let this video
we're just going to kind of like talk
and speculate about
what what we think or what may happen
and and the questions that we have for
for the last half of uh
breaking bad right so we end last season
i mean the big thing of uh not even last
season the last half of the season right
with with uh hank finding uh walt's book
yep the walt whitman remembering that
quote and seeing the initials and yeah
yeah that gail had like
you know
so now he knows
that walt is heisenberg yeah we know
something's going to go down because in
the
uh premiere of season five you know the
first episode we see walter at that
diner yes you know with uh different ids
got some huge it's a year later a year
later right some huge gun he just
ordered you know with instructions of
the guy printed off off the internet so
you know there's going to be some kind
of a showdown something's going to
happen in the season big that's a big
question what's going to happen with
walt versus hank because
hey okay hank knows now right
he he's smart enough not to go he's not
gonna go out of that bathroom and go
walt i know you're heisenberg no he's
gonna he's gonna prove it he's gonna get
evidence exactly he's gonna follow him
he's going to watch him now
if we believe what walter said at the
end of the first half of seas part one
season five it said he told scholar he's
out he made a big amount of money he
paid jesse his 5 million he got his 5
million everybody had their cut
everybody's paid and he said he's out
he's made enough money supposedly he's
out so
i wonder how hank's going to get
evidence are walter still going to be in
the game when the season starts is still
going to be anything or is he going to
find it some other way they hinted that
it wasn't because the way that their
the marriage i guess i'm
the family was kind of back together
exactly they didn't really say how long
that had been you know could have been a
few days it could have been a week or
whatever
but i assume that that
he has stopped he has actually really
stopped and that's why their marriage is
coming back because otherwise he'd have
to disappear all all day you know they
have all this money they can do whatever
the hell they want right
so my guess is that he is out my
question is
between him and in the whole like the
check deal and that the claim guy or
whatever that's distributing in in
arizona yeah
how did they take that news like okay
here's this guy who makes the best bet
because if we remember anything from
watching gangster shows sopranos movies
godfather goodfellas you can't just get
out yeah you know every time they pulled
me they pulled me back in you know that
famous quote like you can't get out of
the game so i feel like someone's gonna
come back after him or come confront him
somehow i think that's probably how he's
gonna get back in or you know he's gonna
expose he's going to get exposed
something's going to happen like that or
somebody from the outside might come in
and disrupt his life yeah but so i think
hank has to go
uh backwards right and look for evidence
in previous cases versus
trying to get any new stuff because
let's say he tails him and he's not
doing it so right then what he can't
catch him red-handed he needs to find
you know other evidence right right so
yeah i mean what you know and then
there's going to be a some sort of big
showdown i mean we don't know why
apparently walt was in new hampshire he
had that car with the new hampshire
plates he had the license within
the area yeah why was he out there i
mean he's cancer-free now he's got his
hair
back he's
uh yeah why does he have that gun why
i think that it's like it's not just a
machine it's a heavy alt artillery it's
like
you know you need to be in the army to
have one
it almost looks like he's coming back to
something because he even told the lady
at the diner the server saying he's like
no i'm just here like he's here he's
showing up he has a big gun like he's
going to do work on somebody but as
opposed to like he could just seems like
he could have stayed out and yeah i'm
sure if he was out there but he's not so
yeah i wonder who the confrontation the
confrontation is going to be
between him and hank or someone else oh
it seems almost like he maybe he's on
the run like at some point in these
eight episodes
maybe you know hank does confront him or
something maybe he lets him go right
maybe he says hey you can go off yeah i
don't know but that's that's one of the
big questions and then you know i guess
another question is what's going to end
up happening with uh with his wife yeah
little skylar like anna gunn and his
family in general because now he's moved
back home the kids are back home now
everything's going great
so you know this is breaking bad it's
it's not gonna stay okay or and walter
we talked about you know reviewing the
show the last couple years that he is
he's he's a villain i mean he's not the
good guy now he is yeah he starts off as
kind of a good guy that you root for and
then he's turned in then you hit you
know you had uh gustav gus yeah
he was kind of like the villain of
season four but season five we really
get into
walt disney
the villain right i don't even know if
you could even call him an anti-hero no
you know like i mean
like because tony soprano like he was
one of those guys he was like a bad guy
you know but like you really he's
lovable and you liked him and you
laughed at him while like i'm watching
him like man he's just a bad guy now
well there's things throughout the
series where you you know there was
still a lot of likable things sure more
and more he's becoming more and more
unlikable and a lot of the stuff that he
does say that sounds kind of nice or
whatever is usually
right
usually uh
he's lying yeah or there's an ulterior
motive yeah behind me and i think
everybody was wondering you know i
myself included what's going to happen
at the end of the season and i think i
hope gillian doesn't just kill him off i
think that'd be too easy for him like i
think his family's going to suffer i
think the people closest to him are
going to suffer but i hope that it's not
just going to kill him be like oh you
know that's how he's punished for his
crimes i hope it's something well i
think it's going to be some sort of big
showdown between him and jesse i don't
think he i mean hank may factor into
that but the hank walt relationship is
as powerful as that no i mean this show
is about i mean more so than walt and
skyler it's about walt and jesse yeah
and and you know the last time
they saw each other
jesse thought walt was going to kill him
that's why he had that gun
you know he he got his money he's got
his money yeah he has 5 million i mean
for all walt's crazy villainous he paid
up his money and also he does care about
jesse that's what's so interesting about
his character in the show is that
yeah he's the villain now but you know
that he still cares about jeff that's
why he wanted him so much to stay into
it he had nothing to do with like oh
you're the he kept telling him you're
the best cook just like me
and whatnot it's like okay well he got
that todd guy he did fine with him yeah
sad stuff but but what he really wanted
was that relationship jesse that
father-son relationship that he
quite frankly doesn't really have with
his own real son and obviously stuff
between skyler and him even if their
family's getting kind of better it's not
going to be ever
i guess what it was in the past no no
it's always going to have some drama
with it
yeah so yeah i expect some sort of uh
showdown also one of the things too uh
the poison the the ricin
yeah like
how is that going to factor in because
it's been you know throughout the whole
series
they've been showing it and hinting in
and you know
walt keeps getting it and putting it
back behind the the i know you can just
won't just throw it away well he almost
tried to kill lydia yeah with it right
you know during their meet um and now
with uh
you know i've just seen now this is just
you know seeing stuff on amc they keep
showing like previews they're only show
pieces of what's gonna happen new season
they show stuff from old episodes we've
seen a lot of footage of kristen
ritter's character um that jesse his old
girlfriend used to date and how walt
kind of just obviously just like watched
her die yeah we wonder if that might
come and kill her he didn't kill her no
but he didn't save he didn't save her
right and it was probably like an easy
save right
i think that definitely is gonna play
out somehow
either jesse's gonna find out or walt's
gonna confess to him because
remember walt almost confessed to him in
that episode with the fly right when
they were yeah when they were in the
super lab he was kind of delirious and
whatnot he almost told jesse so i
definitely think that's going to play
into
into j jesse's like
okay walt disney yeah he's an [ __ ]
right he's the villain now like because
right now jesse
he's kind of teeter in that line like
bolt's unstable he knows he's unstable
but he's
he's still kind of loyal to him exactly
yeah and then his other kid i wonder if
he's going to show up some maury of uh
todd yeah yeah todd you know
i think was kind of impressed by him you
know because when he killed that kid you
know and you know when they were doing
that train heist yeah um walt was like
oh maybe we should but he was kind of
looking at him that was a little
admiration even though he's a little
saying like yeah maybe we should have
done that but you know hey got the job
done he's ruthless but you know jesse
kind of hesitates on things like that
because he has some sense of morality um
but i think walt is going darker and
darker he might lean on tout or what's
todd and do is todd even making this
stuff i mean walt's out so what's he
doing is he even around no but i mean he
must have made a good chunk of change
from all that
he's also a loose end because walt uh
had him and his his his uh aryan
brotherhood uncle yeah do the whole
killing killing of all the people in the
prison so
he's also someone that can rat out right
well if it's needed so i think we're
noticing just talking about this with
you again just remembering how i've
almost forgotten how many different
people can actually come out yeah you
have the drug dealers that have their
thing you have jesse you have todd all
these people can actually his family
skyler is somewhat of a danger you know
she's a loose cannon scott can get crazy
so i mean who knows and the question is
where is skyler going to fall when right
i mean eventually she's going to find
out that hank does
know
whether it's privately or publicly where
is she going to decide on that
yeah she can't keep saying uh he wants
somebody at the casino
problem got gambling issues
okay and then so what do you think is
going to happen to the lawyer saul
cause he's been kind of like this kind
of comedic relief he's the one like such
a dark show he's a comedic relief i hope
he stays alive the whole time i hope
he's i just love the drama when he's
dealing with wall dealing with jesse and
just just he's just it's just so funny
when he's in the room it's just so
comedic so i hope i hope he's around i
hope i see a lot of do you think he's
going to be in prison prisoner
by the time prison maybe okay i hope
he's not dead i don't want to see him
dead what about some of the other
characters like
is hank gonna make it okay
i could see hank not making it really
yeah he's gonna die i think he's gonna
die like i said i think people around
walt will die maybe even jesse um i
think the hero if there is a story maybe
jesse lives well jesse is now kind of
the
hero of the show not necessarily our
typical hero he tries to do the good
thing yeah even though he's kind of
caught up in this drug thing he tries to
do the right thing so i don't know but i
think yeah i think hank i think he's
going to be gone
um
skyler skyler or his son like so there
has to be some collateral damage from
all somebody i mean it's gonna be kind
of hard to kill a poor kid with a you
know thing that he has but i mean it's
like you know it's like
somebody's gotta die around him i think
he i think his son
you know uh walt jr flynn
right yeah i think he's going to be
uh parentless i think him
whether skyler dies or not maybe she
dies or maybe she goes to prison as well
she's done a lot of bad things as well
and then maybe
yeah they they the
mom and dad die hang dies and then he
has to go him and his baby sister have
to go live with his aunt the the one who
steals a lot
the crazy one yeah um so and then
jesse where do you think jesse's gonna
end up oh man i don't know about jesse i
i think he's gonna live i hope so i
think he's gonna live
he's like the one hero i hope he does
live and i think walt is either going to
die
or be in prison or
be like
uh on the run
in mexico or someplace without his
family alone all alone
with nothing right exactly i can see
that happen i mean because i think
that's like the harshest punishment you
can give to walt because i think i guess
it's too easy just to kill him we just
kill him it's like okay i want to
actually see him alive
with his life and you know ruins and
what that looks like for him after that
as opposed to him just dying i think
that'd be too easy i don't know we'll
see so with the poison
do you think like either
skylar or jesse
may
use that against walt in any way maybe
that's how walt dies and then ironing
out that would be good or does walt use
it against jesse or someone else or
somebody actually get a hold of it
accidentally and then something bad
happens like an innocent gets killed i
don't know because it's definitely
coming into play yeah they keep showing
it yeah not only that yeah people like
uh who have gone on set visits that said
oh that
that was on set yeah it's still there so
i don't know
somebody i think that will cause the
death of somebody on this season i think
so i just don't know who it was going to
be walter do it to somebody or somebody
doing to him i don't know all right
so yeah the so the series is ending the
premiere is uh next week uh let us know
what your theories are and how it's
gonna end who do you think is gonna live
who's gonna die who's going to prison
what you know kind of things do you
think are gonna happen in terms of uh
leading to walt's eventual
maybe not demise but
his he's gonna fall somehow he's gonna
his downfalls
is coming so yeah you can post your
comments and theories on our website
thinkcare.com or on our youtube channel
uh below you also find us on dennis
knight both on twitter i'm at griffinde
and i'm at think hero and also subscribe
to our youtube channel that's
thinkheropro and we also have a facebook
page that's facebook.com think hero fans